estos estudiantes de medicina eran solo
niños cuando los separatistas pro rusos
tomaron su ciudad natal en el este de
ucrania la ciudad de donets marcada por
la guerra ha estado en el centro de un
conflicto durante casi una década la
región en disputa es reconocida por la
comunidad internacional como ucraniana
pero está bajo el control de los
separatistas respaldados por rusia pero
no pasando todavía es peligroso aquí da
miedo porque durante mi infancia en
dónetsk escuché la guerra los bombardeos
los tanques rodando por la ciudad cuando
mis amigos y yo salíamos a caminar lo
que no era frecuente esto es lo que
vimos tanques por todas partes y gente
con armas son el huye estas casas
dañadas y con marcas de disparos en la
ciudad industrial son testimonio de un
conflicto más amplio que se cobró unas
13 mil vidas donestsk ha estado bajo
toque de queda nocturno durante 8 años
recientemente se levantó los fines de
semana pero los estudiantes dicen que la
ciudad es un pueblo fantasma y esa
guerra les ha robado tanto la esperanza
como las expectativas y estoy cansado de
la situación el conflicto no tiene
sentido claro porque la guerra continúa
es como una especie de conflicto sin fin
que creciera aquí fue sin duda
estresante fue un poco aterrador al
principio pero luego de alguna manera
nos acostumbramos pero ahora las
explosiones los tiroteos se han vuelto
tan comunes incluso familiares también
sólo un puñado de empresas hacen
negocios aquí hay un banco y un operador
de telefonía móvil comentan puedes irte
de vacaciones el extranjero pero
necesita reunir un montón de documentos
y no está garantizado que te den salir y
no hay garantía que te dejen volver a
entrar
dado que viajará al territorio
controlado por ucrania es casi imposible
muchos ven a rusia como la única ruta
para escapar otros siguen resignados a
vivir bajo la larga sombra de la guerra